das Bundesfinanzministerium hat die
Haushaltssperre vom Klima und
transformationsfond fast auf den
gesamten Bundeshaushalt ausgeweitet das
geht aus einem Schreiben des
Ministeriums hervor bestehende
Verbindlichkeiten würden weiter
eingehalten neue dürften aber nicht
eingegangen werden hieß es Daniel ponsen
in Berlin was bedeutet das denn jetzt
für die Handlungsfähigkeit der
ampelregierung das heißt dass die
Ministerien jetzt keine mehrjährigen
Ausgaben mehr zusagen können genau das
sind nämlich diese sogenannten
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen die jetzt
gesperrt worden sind für die Ampel
insgesamt heißt das dass der Spielraum
natürlich jetzt massiv gekürzt wird
gewissermaßen zurück auf Los allerdings
mit viel weniger Geld zur Verfügung als
man beim ersten Start
glaubte im Grunde gibt's jetzt zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder massiv sparen
priorisieren sich auf Kernanliegen
beschränken und gegebenfalls auch
Ausgaben kürzen auch Sozialausgaben das
ist schwer zu machen mit Grünen und SPD
zweite Möglichkeit doch noch mal die
Schuldenbremse aussetzen nachträglich
für dieses Jahr und oder fürs nächste
das ist zumindest stand jetzt schwer mit
der FDP zu machen auch da gibt's
verfassungsrechtliche Zweifel insofern
ist es in jedem Fall die zumindest
finanziell schwerste Belastungsprobe für
die Ampel und wie groß die Auswirkung
tatsächlich sind auch darüber hat man ja
noch keine genaue Klarheit dazu gibt's
gleich eine Expertenanhörung im
Bundestag von 11r bis 1 Uhr Daniel
ponsen vielen Dank